En este video vamos a pensar en cómo se
organizarán los iones cuando formen cristales
sólidos, cuando forman estas estructuras
reticulares. En términos muy generales,
digamos que tenemos un montón de este catión
blanco y tenemos un montón de este anión verde
o azul verde; también digamos que están
en una relación 1 a 1, ¿cómo se verá eso?,
¿cómo se vería el sólido si hiciéramos un corte
bidimensional? Para imaginar esto, podemos
dibujar lo que llamamos modelos de partículas.
Sólo estamos imaginando un corte bidimensional
del sólido, y estamos dibujando estos iones como
partículas. Se vería algo así, donde tal vez el
ion positivo está en un lado y el ion negativo
está en el otro lado, en la parte inferior. Si
tuviéramos que tomar una rebanada, ¿tendría
sentido algo como esto? O tal vez es al azar;
tal vez tenemos un positivo ahí y luego tenemos
algunos negativos allí, y luego tal vez tengamos
algunos positivos y positivo y luego positivo
ahí, y entonces quizá tengamos algunos negativos
ahí. ¿Sería esta una configuración razonable
conforme se forman estos enlaces iónicos? Bueno,
cuando pensamos en las fuerzas de Coulomb sabemos
que las cargas similares se repelen entre sí,
a diferencia de las cargas opuestas que se
atraen entre sí, por lo que, cuando se forman
estos sólidos iónicos es poco probable que se
formen de esta manera o incluso de esta manera,
porque se formarán de manera que se maximicen las
fuerzas de atracción y se minimicen las fuerzas
de repulsión. Entonces, ¿qué tipo de arreglo haría
eso? Pausen el video y piénsenlo. Todas las cargas
positivas tratarán de acercarse lo más posible a
las cargas negativas y alejarse lo más que puedan
de otras cargas positivas, y lo mismo ocurrirá con
las cargas negativas: intentarán alejarse lo más
posible de otras cargas negativas y acercarse lo
más posible a las cargas positivas. Por lo tanto,
la disposición que probablemente veremos se
parecerá más al patrón de un tablero de ajedrez:
podría ser positivo ahí, positivo ahí, positivo
ahí, positivo ahí y positivo ahí. Todos son el
mismo ion. No lo estoy dibujando perfectamente,
tendrían que ser del mismo tamaño. Y cuando
hacemos estas representaciones bidimensionales,
estos modelos de partículas, es importante tener
el tamaño correcto; pero vamos a ver eso en un
momento. Y luego las cargas negativas estarían
en medio, así que en esta configuración todo lo
negativo está rodeado de cargas positivas y todo
lo positivo está rodeado de cargas negativas,
por lo que se están maximizando las fuerzas de
atracción y minimizando las fuerzas de repulsión.
Y si lo pensáramos en tres dimensiones tendríamos
una estructura reticular parecida a esta, que
hemos visto en otros videos. Ahora, otra cosa
interesante que debemos pensar es el tamaño de los
iones que forman ese sólido iónico. Digamos que
tenemos bromuro de rubidio. ¿Cómo sería esto si lo
dibujara en un modelo de partículas bidimensional
como este y quisiera hacer que el tamaño sea más
o menos comparable a lo que veríamos entre el
rubidio y el bromuro? Pausen el video y piensen en
esto, y les daré una pequeña pista: puede ser útil
mirar la tabla periódica de los elementos. Muy
bien. Si tuviéramos que separar esto en sus iones:
tenemos 1 catión rubidio y 1 anión bromuro;
1 catión rubidio ha perdido un electrón y,
aunque todavía tiene 37 protones, su configuración
electrónica ahora se parece más a la del criptón;
el anión bromuro, aunque sólo tiene 35 protones,
ganará un electrón para convertirse en 1 anión
bromuro y también tendrá una configuración
electrónica parecida al criptón. Entonces
ambos tienen la misma cantidad de electrones, pero
el rubidio tiene 2 protones más que el bromuro,
y así el rubidio atraerá esa capa externa de
electrones, esa cuarta capa de electrones,
más de lo que lo hará el núcleo de bromuro. El
rubidio, en este ejemplo, será más pequeño que el
bromuro. Y si dibujara uno de estos diagramas se
vería así. Permítanme dibujar el bromuro primero.
Así que tenemos 1 anión bromuro, tenemos otro
anión bromuro, otro anión bromuro, tal vez hay un
anión bromuro por aquí, un anión bromuro por allá,
tal vez algunos más. Si estuviéramos haciendo esto
con una computadora los haríamos todos del
mismo tamaño. Entonces, estos son nuestros
aniones bromuro, y luego los cationes rubidio
serían un poco más pequeños. Queremos dejar en
claro que el catión es un poco más pequeño que
el anión; probablemente se organizarían en un
patrón que se parezca a esto. Y vean que estoy
tratando de hacer que los tamaños sean más o
menos precisos para mostrar que el catión es,
de hecho, más pequeño que el anión, aunque no
sería dramáticamente más pequeño. Recuerden
que tiene la misma cantidad de electrones y
no tiene un número dramáticamente diferente de
protones. Este es sólo un dibujo muy tosco. Si
fueran dramáticamente diferentes podríamos
mostrarlo en los tamaños en este diagrama.